منها كانت بدايه الجائحه اول حاله لكوفيت
19 يعتقد انها سجلت في وهران وكما يبدو
فان الصين ستتاخر اكثر من سواها في خفض
تداعيات الجارحه
لم يكن ناجعا هكذا تقول الارقام رفعت
الاجراءات بدايه كانون الاول ديسمبر
الماضي فاتهمت بيجين بالتكتم على الاصابات
ما لبست بعدها ان اعلنت عن احصائيات صادمه
او يزيد سجلتها المستشفيات منذ الثامنه من
كانون الاول ديسمبر حتى الثاني عشر من
كانون الثاني يناير
ما قد يعني ان اعداد الوفيات الفعليه قد
يكون اعلى من ذلك لمصابين لم يتلقوا
العلاج في المستشفيات
لجنه الصحه
الحاليه سجلتها البلاد اواخر العام الماضي
بمعدل اصابه بلغ ثلاثه وثلاثين وتسعه
اعشار في المئه بين الاشخاص الذين خضعوا
للفحص لتنخفض الى عشره وثمانيه اعشار في
المئه بحلول الثاني عشر من الشهر الحالي
فما الذي جرى قبل الاعلان
في الثامن من الشهر الحالي فتحت الصين
حدودها امام الرحلات الدوليه بعد ثلاثه
اعوام من القيود المشدده
في الداخل دفعت الاضرابات والاحتجاجات غير
المسبوقه الى التخلي عن سياسه صفر كوفد
لتعلن لجنه الصحه الوطنيه بعدها انها
ستنقل المرض من فئه الف الى فئه باب
واعاده تسميه الفيروس من الالتهاب الرئوي
الناجم عن فيروس كورونا الجديد الى عدوى
فيروس كورونا الجديد وعلى ما يبدو فان
الرياح تسير عكس اجراءات بيتين